zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
et bienvenue dans zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 une émission
enregistrée en Espagne l'Espagne est
membre de l'Union européenne depuis le
1er janvier 1986 elle est aussi membre
de la zone euro depuis le 1er janvier
1999 et pour ce numéro spécial nous
sommes à Madrid deuxième plus grande
ville de l'Union européenne derrière
Berlin la capitale espagnole est connue
pour ses nombreux musées un club de foot
prestigieux le Real le farniente et
enfin ses éventails
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment elle est conne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la France est le premier partenaire
commercial de l'Espagne j'ai rendez-vous
avec Bertrand Barthélemy le directeur de
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
franco-espagnole une institution à
laquelle plus de 600 entreprises
adhérent
bonjour Bertrand Barthélémy
cette institution qui est la CCI
France-Espagne existe depuis la fin du
19e siècle quelles sont ses missions et
ses principaux objectifs alors la
chambre franco-espagnol a été créée en
1894 à l'origine c'était une initiative
qui a été lancée par des entrepreneurs
français qui étaient présents en Espagne
la mission clairement a évolué sur la
période donc maintenant à l'heure
actuelle nous sommes une association qui
regroupe un peu plus de 550 sociétés
adhérentes et nous avons une double
finalité d'une part nous sommes un club
d'affaires c'est-à-dire que nous animons
cette communauté d'affaires et par
ailleurs nous sommes également un
prestataire de service qui accompagne
les entreprises françaises sur le marché
espagnol et les entreprises espagnoles
sur le marché français alors pour faire
ce travail nous sommes donc basés à
Madrid nous avons notre siège nous avons
une équipe de 17 collaborateurs
permanents et ce sont à peu près une
centaine d'activités que nous proposons
à nous adhérents tout au long de l'année
sur des thématiques bien concrètes en
sachant qu'à chaque fois nous cherchons
à apporter des contenus à apporter des
échanges de bonne pratique pour que les
entreprises apprennent une des autres et
à promouvoir sur tous les contacts entre
elles pour qu'elles puissent se
développer et développer comme ça un
courant d'affaires donc c'est la plupart
de ces activités se développent au sein
de commission sectorielles nous avons
l'heure actuelle une dizaine de
commissions sectorielles et en matière
de service nous accompagnons les
entreprises françaises sur le marché
espagnol dans toutes les phases de leur
implantation en travaillant en
collaboration avec la team France Export
et nous apprenions nous accompagnons
également les entreprises espagnoles sur
le marché français banlieue on parle
beaucoup du couple franco-allemand comme
moteur économique qu'en est-il des
relations économiques entre la France et
l'Espagne
alors les relations économiques entre la
France et l'Espagne sont très intenses
ou très longtemps c'est je pense la
chance qu'à une structure comme la nôtre
d'être dans un pays où il y a finalement
une très forte la proximité de la France
et donc une forte richesse des échanges
nous avons identifié à peu près ici
entre 1500 et 2000 filiales françaises
et toutes ces entreprises contribuent à
ce que la France soit le premier
partenaire commercial de l'Espagne c'est
son premier client et son deuxième
fournisseur alors que l'Espagne pour sa
part et le 5e client et le 4e
fournisseur de la France vous
accompagner les entreprises françaises
qui veulent s'implanter en Espagne vous
l'avez dit aujourd'hui quels sont les
principales difficultés qu'elles peuvent
rencontrer alors je voudrais pas faire
peur aux entrepreneurs qui veulent venir
ici c'est clair qu'il existe des
difficultés mais il faut pas non plus
mettre l'accent sur ces difficultés je
pense que la principale peut être
d'une part le fait qu'on est pas
réellement une unité de marché puisque
il y a des communautés autonomes en
Espagne il y a 17 communautés autonome
et de villes autonomes qui sont
l'équivalent de région je dirais mais
avec un pouvoir qui est beaucoup plus
décentralisé et donc en fait vous pouvez
avoir des législations locales suivant
les secteurs qui peuvent impacter au
moment de du développement d'une
entreprise suivant le secteur dans
lequel il opère donc ça c'est une
première chose je pense la deuxième
élément qu'il faudrait considérer quand
on veut aborder le marché espagnol c'est
que la proximité de la France peut faire
croire que c'est un marché de proximité
qui est simple avec des similitudes
culturelles alors qu'en fait il y a une
dimension interculturelle de la
négociation qui ne faut pas négliger et
qui peut qui peut faire que des
entreprises commettent des impairs si
elles ne connaissent pas réellement la
culture de l'autre pays d'où l'intérêt
de se faire accompagner par des
interlocuteurs qui sont plus que je
dirais bilingue vie culturel alors nous
sommes à Madrid aujourd'hui mais vous
avez également d'autres délégations
territoriales partout dans le pays
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres communautés
autonomes espagnoles qui peuvent être
intéressantes du point de vue économique
pour les entreprises françaises oui
alors à l'occasion de notre 120e
anniversaire la Chambre a amené une
réflexion sur son développement
territorial nous avions une délégation
historique à Valence puisque la
communauté Valenciennes est une des
régions à fort potentiels en Espagne et
suite à la réflexion qui était menée aux
opportunités que nous avons identifiées
nous sommes implantés dans les régions
où là où nous voyons le plus fort
potentiel nous sommes par exemple en
Andalousie avec deux délégations une
amalaga et une assez vie nous sommes
également au Pays Basque avec une
délégation à Bilbao en Aragon avec une
délégation à Saragosse en castillole
avec une délégation riadolides et puis
ensuite nous sommes dans les îles aux
Baléares à Palma et au Canaries à
Tenerife et ce sont les communautés où
nous avons identifié le plus fort
potentiel enfin pour finir on est dans
un contexte un peu compliqué post covid
est-ce que justement c'est un bon moment
pour pour se lancer pour entreprendre en
Espagne ou au contraire il faut attendre
encore un petit peu
alors j'aurais tendance à dire que pour
toute entreprise qui a un projet sérieux
qui est bien préparé c'est un bon moment
pour entreprendre je dirais qu'au niveau
de nos activités c'est vrai que nous
avons souffert de la pandémie puisque
nous nous vendons du réseau du contact
et puis également donc des mises en
rapport d'entreprises et de pays avec la
pandémie tout cela s'est freiné très
fortement mais une activité que nous
avons qui s'est maintenue et qui a
progressé était celle justement d'aide à
l'implantation le domiciliation et de
gestion administrative et on se rend
compte que maintenant on a beaucoup de
demandes d'entreprises qui veulent
s'implanter ici donc ça peut être soit
des filiales soit des Français qui
viennent en Espagne et qui montent un
établissement permanent ou qui montre
une structure propre qu'on peut appeler
un établissement français à l'étranger
[Musique]
ça s'appelle la maison allumée car c'est
le nom d'un poème d'un poète espagnol
des années 50 qui s'appelle Luis rozalez
en plus c'est l'idée très belle d'un
espace vivant rempli de gens une maison
allumée c'est un musée dans lequel des
gens vivent et c'est un peu l'idée de ce
lieu un espace dans lequel il se passe
toujours quelque chose et remplit
d'énergie
quelles sont les différentes missions de
la Casa snvida à quoi sert-elle
la Fondation
est un centre culturel et social de la
Fondation montée Madrid nous sommes
principalement concentrés sur la culture
contemporaine pour comprendre le présent
et répondre un peu aux différentes
problématiques qui se produisent de nos
jours à travers quatre Aires d'action
que sont la culture l'environnement la
solidarité
spécifiquement sur le covid elle veut
nous faire réfléchir comment les virus
nous affectent tant nous les humains
comme les non humains et nous devons
commencer à pouvoir vivre avec eux de la
meilleure manière possible d'une autre
manière ils invitent aussi à retrouver
le contact cette dernière pandémie le
choc que nous avons eu nous a aussi
isolé séparé et cette exposition est une
manière de retrouver l'idée d'être à
nouveau ensemble alors on a mal
exposition intéressante elle s'appelle
inédit 2022 cette année c'est la
vingtième édition d'inédine c'est quoi
le
concepto
à la maison animée avec la Fondation
espagnol
moins de 35 ans le concours pour que
présente leurs projets
et nous la présentons à la maison animée
quels sont les deux projets gagnants
cette année cette année
les deux projets gagnants cette année
sont deux projets féminins Nuria Gomez
Gabriel qui a présenté un projet qui
s'appelle les méchants qui à travers
différentes œuvres d'artistes
contemporains nous fait réfléchir sur
l'idée du mal et comme certaines fois
nous voyons l'idée du mal comme quelque
chose qui est en dehors de nous on
comprend que non c'est quelque chose que
nous partageons tous et la deuxième
exposition s'appelle devenir une île de
Enya pomer claquelle c'est une réflexion
sur l'idée d'îles et d'archipel c'est
aussi l'idée d'un appel à être de
nouveau ensemble à comprendre les
différentes relations et différentes
questions qui peuvent se poser
merci beaucoup
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
du musée la casa nsendida
[Musique]
l'Espagne c'est la première destination
Erasmus pour les étudiants français ils
étaient en 2021
4267 avenir étudier ici et découvrir une
nouvelle culture je vais tout de suite
rendez-vous avec alphonseau rentyl le
directeur du service pour
l'internationalisation de l'éducation
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous dans un
Europe bonjour c'est un plaisir à voir
avec vous aujourd'hui alors todo el
mundo tout le monde connaît le programme
Erasmus mais c'est quoi
Erasmus plus et ses priorités priori
d'Hadès et l'amour plus est un programme
qui s'adresse à tout le secteurs
éducatifs de l'éducation scolaire à
l'éducation supérieure mais aussi à
l'éducation pour les adultes et les
formations professionnelles et ce n'est
pas seulement un programme de mobilité
étudiante mais aussi de professeurs et
de professionnels il va plus loin le
plus va plus loin que la mobilité on
souhaite améliorer les centres éducatifs
et tous les bénéficiaires qui
participent au programme les priorités
pour la période 2021 2027 sont la
digitalisation la durabilité ou
l'environnement la participation et la
vie démocratique et l'inclusion cette
en 2022 nous célébrons les 35 ans du
programme Erasmus et c'est l'année aussi
de la jeunesse dans l'Union européenne
tout cela a-t-il un impact sur les
travaux du CP sauvez l'os traba rose
delpieds spécifiques pour célébrer ce
35e anniversaire avec chacun des
secteurs et nous collaborons avec
l'agence de la jeunesse en Espagne elle
s'appelle une trouvée pour d'autres
actions en rapport avec l'Année de la
jeunesse
quels sont les derniers chiffres de
participation des étudiants de
l'éducation supérieure espagnole et quel
est le pays qui choisissent le plus en
Europe et Europa leader les chiffres les
plus actualisés que nous avons date de
2019 c'est plus de 40 900 étudiants
espagnols qui sont allés dans d'autres
pays européens du programme
Erasmus plus la première destination et
l'Italie après le Royaume-Uni et la
France est en troisième position suivi
de l'Allemagne et de la Pologne
donc contrario dans le sens inverse
l'Espagne est la première destination
Erasmus pour les étudiants français
comment expliquer vous ce succès
successo
l'Espagne la première destination
Erasmus en général dans le secteur de
l'éducation supérieure la majorité des
pays européens choisissent l'Espagne pas
seulement les Français le succès des
universités espagnoles se doit au fait
qu'elles sont bien situées dans les
classements pour ce qui est de la
connaissance nous sommes un pays leader
dans le secteur de la recherche nous
avons une grande qualité de vie nos
universités et sont situés dans les
centres-villes nous avons aussi des
campus aux abords des villes pour des
raisons de confort en conclusion nous
avons une offre aussi bien culturelle
gastronomique de qualité de vie et
surtout des universités de qualité ce
qui fait que nous sommes chaque fois
plus attractifs
à un jeune espagnol quand il revient en
Espagne après sa mobilité il a une
meilleure employabilité
les gens qui participent au programme
Erasmus plus en général améliore leurs
compétences pour trouver un travail plus
de 90% de ceux qui ont vécu une mobilité
à ce muscle trouve un emploi dans
l'année qui suit la fin de leurs études
et 80% de ceux qui ont participé au
programme nous disent via l'enquête qui
a réalisé la Commission européenne
qu'ils ont amélioré leur capacité pour
parler comme pour comprendre les autres
parler d'autres langues ils peuvent donc
trouver du travail plus facilement
comment
facilement merci beaucoup
[Musique]
qui est chouette
l'Espagne reçoit environ 48 000
étudiants en Erasmus chaque année dont
9,8% de français rencontre avec certains
d'entre eux alors je m'appelle Audrey
gravine Mercier j'ai 20 ans alors je
m'appelle Taïs j'ai 20 ans et je suis en
3ème année de l'Angleterre et
civilisations espagnoles et je fais ma
troisième année en est responsa Madrid
pourquoi avoir fait une mobilité la
principale
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on s'y et j'ai découvert
aussi que du coup je pouvais apprendre
bien plus que ça une nouvelle culture un
nouveau mode de vie enfin beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres choses plus tard je
veux faire professeur d'espagnol donc
faire un Erasmus en Espagne c'était
quelque chose de un peu obligatoire pour
moi parce que je voulais m'améliorer
etc et la vie madrilène c'est la vie
quand on pense à la vie espagnole c'est
ça c'est la capitale etc donc en quoi
cette expérience va-t-elle vous servir
selon moi ça c'est un plus dans
l'enrichissement qu'on peut faire au
niveau du travail j'ai appris des
nouvelles méthodes de travail avec des
oui des nouvelles personnes des nouveaux
professeurs mais qui sont tout autre que
ce qu'on peut apprendre en France et
aussi d'un point de vue donc
professionnel mais aussi personnel ou on
a enfin personnellement j'ai énormément
grandi et évolué c'est une autre
autonomie qu'on acquiert donc beaucoup
de choses sur ces deux plans là la vie à
Madrid va me servir pour connaître
culturellement l'Espagne vraiment et pas
rester dans dans des a priori ou des
dire qu'on m'a fait plutôt dans ma vie
etc
quel est votre quotidien une journée
type à Madrid en tant que Erasmus elle
est elles peuvent être assez chargées
mais parce que nous on les remplit bien
on commence les cours plus ou moins on
fait nos propres emploi du temps donc ça
varie personnellement je commençais
plutôt vers 10h et je finissais vers 21h
mais j'avais des jours après de libre
dans la semaine
euh donc on va en cours le midi on se
retrouve avec nos amis on va à la
cafétéria on a des heures de pause on
bosse on bosse ensemble et puis le soir
souvent on avait des soirées de libre on
pouvait se rejoindre faire plus des
activités culturelles ou même sortir
entre nous et aller boire un verre on se
lève on va à l'université
en général on retrouve ses amis moi je
retrouve une amie tous les matins on
prend le métro ensemble on va en courant
ensemble et le soir on rentre on envoie
des messages dans des groupes pour
savoir qui veut aller sortir prendre un
verre aller faire un pique-nique etc et
on rencontre du monde que ce soit
français espagnol et toutes les
nationalités
que dire aux jeunes pour les convaincre
de faire une mobilité qu'il faut pas
hésiter du tout vraiment Nancy a bien
une expérience à faire c'est de partir
moi je suis parti un an j'ai plus
dure partir de quitter Madrid
oui non ne vraiment pas hésiter et
foncer parce que c'est une expérience
vraiment incroyable on rencontre des
gens incroyables et qui mine de rien je
pense nous nous change un peu pour tout
le reste après de notre vie s'ils ont la
possibilité qu'ils y aille qu'ils aient
pas peur de
oui non s'ils doivent aller en Erasmus
il faut pas qu'ils aient peur s'ils en
ont la possibilité que ce soit pour la
langue que ce soit pour
je sais pas n'importe quelle peur qu'ils
ont peur d'être autonome non il faut y
aller faut foncer et c'est une
expérience inoubliable et ils vont ils
vont adorer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment elle est conne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Madrid est une ville incontournable en
Europe la capitale espagnole regorge de
lieux culturels Alice et Émilie sont
deux expatriés françaises qui ont lancé
un blog vive Madrid nous avons
rendez-vous avec elle
vive Madrid c'est donc un bloc qui
existe maintenant depuis plus de deux
ans qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie à
toutes les deux de vous lancer dans ce
projet
alors on est arrivé toutes les deux à
peu près en même temps il y a 4 ans on
s'est rencontré rapidement après notre
arrivée et on avait un peu la même
problématique c'est qu'on était en
reconversion en fait on avait quitté nos
emplois à Paris pour suivi de conjoint
donc mobilité professionnelle à Madrid
en famille on est venu en famille tous
les deux on s'est rencontrés et Émilie
avait déjà un projet de site internet et
on s'est dit que on allait allier nos
forces pour créer voilà un projet un peu
plus grand un peu plus voilà ambitieux
pour voilà pour pour faire partager aux
expatriés et aux touristes qui viennent
à Madrid
toute notre aventure en fait après il y
avait aussi
une problématique on a rencontré quand
on est arrivé c'est que on avait trouvé
assez peu d'informations sur
l'installation faire tous ses papiers
administratifs etc parce que nous on
n'est pas arrivé dans le cas d'une
expatriation classique professionnelle
donc on a dû tout faire par nous-mêmes
et c'était assez compliqué de trouver
des informations
mises à jour donc on s'était dit que bah
déjà partagé notre propre expérience
pourraient peut-être aider d'autres
Français qui allaient venir s'installer
ici alors ça fait quatre ans maintenant
que vous vivez à Madrid vous nous l'avez
dit quels sont les principales
différences qu'il peut y avoir entre la
vie ici à Madrid et la vie en France
alors en tant que famille je pense que
militant un peu la même remarque en tant
que famille avec des jeunes enfants
c'est vrai que on a trouvé on trouve que
la vie elle est beaucoup plus facile que
c'est voilà l'ambiance est plus relax en
fait quand on est avec des jeunes
enfants quand on se balade dans la rue
dans les quand on va au resto quand on
va dans les musées c'est vrai que ça on
a plus le noter voilà que les Espagnols
et voilà étaient plus patients étaient
plus
passion avec les enfants avec voilà plus
relax ça n'a plus noté après c'est pas
très loin donc c'est assez similaire
mais le rythme de vie bien sûr les
horaires le riz aussi des horaires donc
ça c'est vraiment typique de l'Espagne
c'est que voilà l'heure du déjeuner
beaucoup plus tard lors du des repas
sont décalés et ça il faut s'y faire et
on s'y fait petit à petit et encore on a
encore nos petites habitudes françaises
de temps en temps
après si tu vois oui bah c'est ta dit le
principal ici il y a quand même une
bienveillance générale qui qui rend la
vie quotidienne très très agréable en
fait c'est la vie est douce et
plutôt
bienveillante quoi de manière générale
et avec des familles et
aussi enfin sans être en famille aussi
alors vivre Madrid c'est le nom de votre
blog je le rappelle vous proposez une
série de bons plans pour les touristes
français les expatriés comment est-ce
que vous faites pour trouver dénicher
tous ces tous ces bons plans comment
est-ce que vous vous y prenez
alors on va quand on se balade c'est
vrai qu'on on se dit on va aller dans
telle exposition voir tel musée donc on
général on se balade autour dans Madrid
et dans ce cas là on peut trouver par
hasard des bonnes adresses de
restaurants ou pour pour sortir ou des
parcs et après sinon si on peut se voilà
pour on peut aussi faire des recherches
un petit peu en amont pour savoir par
exemple nous arrivent souvent de
travailler dans des cafés ou voilà on
peut travailler et du coup on essaie de
du coup de chercher un petit peu
en amont des bonnes adresses qu'on l'air
sympa on les teste et puis si c'est bien
on en parle et on partage les adresses
ouais c'est ça c'est un peu de veille et
enfin peu de recherche de veille après
on teste des fois c'est aussi un peu de
bouche à oreille avec des amis espagnols
ou français qui partagent aussi des fois
des lieux
donc c'est un petit peu de tout en fait
et après on partage que ce qu'on aime ce
qu'on a aimé en fait tout ce qu'on
trouve utile en tout cas pour nos
lecteurs à Madrid il y a une grande
communauté française communauté
d'expatriés
quels seraient les quartiers que vous
conseillerez pour de futurs
expatriés justement ou certains qui
hésiteraient à venir s'installer dans la
capitale espagnole
en fait il y a un critère il y a un
critère numéro un pour les familles
généralement elles veulent s'inscrire
elles veulent s'inscrire aux enfants au
lycée français donc déjà ça tout de
suite ça ça limite aussi un pain en
terme de périmètre parce qu'il y a
4 lycées français donc la majorité sont
enfin les deux plus importants sont au
nord de Madrid donc c'est vrai que c'est
souvent là qu'on retrouve les Français
parce que bah ils vivent proche du lycée
français après il y a aussi si vous
n'allez pas au lycée français il y a des
très bonnes écoles
espagnoles et anglophones partout dans
Madrid donc après vous pouvez vivre
partout dans Madrid ou même dans les
environs un petit peu dans l'Ouest aussi
à poszuelo villano Eva de la Canada il y
a aussi des très bonnes écoles
anglaises et françaises donc il y a
aussi des beaucoup d'étrangers d'expates
qui vivent qui vivent là-bas et bien
merci beaucoup Alice et Émilie d'avoir
été avec nous dans zone Europe donc je
rappelle votre blog vive Madrid on peut
retrouver sur internet et sur Instagram
[Musique]
que signifie
un agneau la mort
[Musique]
c'est pas ça
c'est l'heure de manger ici à Madrid
alors quand on pense à la cuisine
espagnole on pense évidemment à la
paella ou tapas on Ramon ou encore à la
tortilla nous avons tout de suite
rendez-vous avec Luis le chef du
restaurant La Barre routière il va nous
présenter une recette
avec nous tuer le chef du restaurant La
barroutia à Madrid quel est l'esprit de
ce lieu les spirituel
fête ses 140 ans donc l'esprit c'est le
poursuivre fidèlement son histoire ce
qui est un peu compliqué si on y pense
j'aurais eu un lieu qui fonctionne bien
depuis 140 ans peut devenir un fardeau
avec mon expérience
j'essaie de faire une très bonne cuisine
qui passe très bien et qui ne soit pas
trop cher
c'est un classique tout Madrid
pratiquement le connaît quoi
la cuisine madrilène je dirais qu'elle
n'existe pas
c'est plutôt une cuisine éclectique il
faut savoir qu'à Madrid il y a des gens
qui viennent de toutes les régions
d'Espagne et même de l'étranger donc la
cuisine de base n'est pas très simple il
y a le fromage cuit les sandwichs au
calamars et les tripes à la madrilène
mais pas grand chose d'autre
il y a une particularité dans la cuisine
madrilène c'est que l'on partage tous
les plats cette esprit de partage il
reflète la cuisse d'espagnol dès qu'on
partirait clairement ici vous pourrez
retrouver le meilleur de tout notre
territoire et aussi beaucoup de
l'Amérique du Sud puisqu'il y a une
grande influence espagnole là-bas et de
eux ici vous pourrez retrouver des
influences péruviennes colombienne et
aussi portugaise ou brésilienne
française aussi bien sûr la cuisine
française tu sais bien qu'elle a dominé
le monde pendant des années et encore
aujourd'hui donc nous allons cuisiner
maintenant pour faire une recette
qu'allons-nous faire avec toi bon alors
aujourd'hui nous allons faire une
recette dans laquelle ce mélange
beaucoup d'ingrédients elle s'appelle
salmorero avec une vinaigrette de
crevettes et du rhum cubain c'est un
plat andalou classique avec une
vinaigrette qui nous vient du Pays
Basque et un rhum de La Havane
allez maintenant on passe en cuisine
se fait avec une bonne tomate comme
cette tomate rouge et le panne du pain
de l'eau de l'huile d'olive extra vierge
de l'ail et du vinaigre de reresse la
première étape
[Musique]
l'eau a continuation ensuite on prend la
mie de pain
si possible on prend du pain qui date de
la veille
on met ça dans un bol et on mélange avec
un petit peu d'eau
[Musique]
ensuite on prend une gousse d'ail
à
il faut enlever le germe car sinon
ça peut te faire mal à l'estomac voilà
voilà
le sel
et le vinaigre
qui reste la traditionnelle et
maintenant notre tradition c'est de
l'écraser avec les mains
nous allons les mélanger avec les
oignons blancs et les tomates que nous
avons aussi assaisonné
un peu de vinaigre du vinaigre de grès
un peu de sel
de l'huile d'olive
un peu de rhum
[Musique]
on mélange tout et ça y est c'est prêt
maintenant
on va passer on va verser la base
[Musique]
et voilà le Bruno le petit truc de ce
plan c'est que l'on n'a pas besoin de le
bouger tu le manges avec ta cuillère de
bas en haut en profitant de cette saveur
fraîche du salon tu auras dans la bouche
les oignons les langoustines les tomates
ce n'est pas seulement une recette de
saveur mais aussi de texture la texture
est fondamentale cela va te donner de la
joie et c'est ce que nous avons besoin
en ce moment
et maintenant on peut passer à la
dégustation
[Musique]
c'est terminé vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio ou vidéo
sur notre site Internet et sur notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
TV 118 bon week-end et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]